another tragic heartbreaking shooting
this time in parkland Florida 17
students and teachers dead after a mass
shooting that just is heartbreaking a
horrific in every way we'll discuss it
we'll break it all down we'll bring you
all the information I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so there's a lot to get to with regard
to this particular shooting another mass
shooting
it's another month and another mass
shooting and this is driven a lot of
folks in the media to do what they
always do after a mass shooting which is
call for gun control and then suggest
that anyone who disagrees with their
prescriptions to solve problems like
this must not care about the people who
died which is one of the things I hate
most about American politics a tragedy
occurs an active evil happens and people
who disagree with the political
prescription that is offered by most
activists side are then deemed to be
uncaring or people who are unfeeling
it's something really despicable I'll
talk about that we'll talk about what
exactly happened in Parkland who did who
failed who succeeded some of the stories
of heroism we'll talk about the response
we'll get to all of that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at trippin comm so
you're planning your next vacation and
you don't want to stay at a hotel
because staying in hotel means
particularly if you have kids they are
stuck in a small room with some with
small screaming people so instead you
decide that you're gonna go out and
you're gonna get a vacation rental well
there are lots of sites that do it
there's only one site that really does
it right and that is tripping calm you
can spend less time planning your next
trip more time relaxing with tripping
calm the world's number one site for
vacation rentals trusted by millions of
travelers for folks like me I need a
kitchenette when we travel because we
obviously cook kosher it's perfect we
don't like staying in hotels we like
staying in vacation rentals you don't
understand how much better it is by the
way to stay in a vacation rental that a
hotel until you've actually stayed in a
place with some square footage tripping
calm onesearch lets you filter compare
and sort over 10 million available
properties on trusted sites like VRBO
TripAdvisor booking calm and more don't
wonder if you're getting the best deal
on that winter cabin or beachfront home
you'll save an average of 18% per night
by booking your vacation with trippin
comm don't forget if you want to save
time and you want to save money while
booking the perfect vacation rental for
your next trip head to trippin comm
slash Shapiro that's trippin comm slash
Shapiro go today book your vacation
you'll feel a lot better about it
whenever my wife is feeling bad about
things whenever we're feeling bad about
things we always look into vacations
because it gives us something to look
forward to so now is the time to book a
great vacation
trippin comm slash Shapiro use that
slash up hero that lets them know that
we sent you and get the best vacation
rental you've ever had trippin comm
slash Shapiro okay so well last night in
the aftermath of this horrific shooting
I was in a pretty terrible mood as I
think most people were who saw the
information it was heartbreaking and
upsetting and deeply disturbing
obviously whenever you see a situation
where somebody walks into a school and
just starts gunning down students and
teachers and last night my daughter was
really misbehaving she's four years old
and she's at the stage where she says no
to everything every everything is a
challenge everything is I have to
threaten to take away her blankies
unless she gets in bed and stops jumping
on the bed says she doesn't crack her
head I mean that's that's basically my
life at night and this morning she woke
up I went in her room and she she stood
up on her bed and she said daddy can I
have a hug and I just thought to myself
it's it's just a horrifying reality that
there are a lot of parents who are
waking up this morning whose kids are
not going to be saying that to them and
it's just if you're not heartbroken
after seeing what just happened in
Florida then you're not a human being
and the idea that that is put forth by
both sides politically depending on the
tragedy and terrorist attack it's people
on the right who save people and left
don't care enough when there's a mass
shooting people on the left say people
on the right don't care enough it's not
about the level of caring everybody
cares everybody is is just weeping with
the families today as as well they
should that does not mean that every
policy prescription is equally valid
equally good or equally valuable and one
of the things that that is so disturbing
and upsetting about how we jump to
conclusions is that as soon as there's a
mass shooting we don't even wait for the
facts to come out everybody leaps to
their respective side so in order to
deal with the problem you first have to
determine what exactly was the problem
what exactly went wrong what exactly
happened here that we can solve that's
not what we do on Twitter
particularly where everybody is is
looking for an instant reaction folks on
the right whatever there's a master
didn't say let's wait for all the facts
and focus on the left when there's a
mass shooting says you don't need any
more facts there have been lots of mass
shootings the United States has more
mass shootings over the past 20 years
than most of the industrialized world
combined that means it's time for a
massive bout of gun control and I
understand the tendency I do I mean I
think that the the tendency to say we
need to do something something has to
stop here is strong but that doesn't
mean that any particular piece of
legislation that's put on the table is
going to be equally valid or that it's
gonna be equally effective at doing this
so during the ramp up usually what it
turns into is folks on the left scream
gun control
come the right say let's wait for all
the facts and then folks on the Left say
all you wanted to his thoughts and
prayers you don't want to do anything
you're deliberately trying to obfuscate
you're deliberately trying to block
progress here that's not what this is
about the question is the there are two
questions one is the question of
sympathy and one is the question of what
we do next and the first question should
not even be on the table everyone cares
about what happened in parkland
yesterday you know the president was
getting ripped up and down this morning
he did a statement about six-minute
statement from the White House talking
about what happened in parkland Florida
and and here's what he had to say my
fellow Americans today I speak to a
nation in grief
yesterday a school filled with innocent
children and caring teachers became the
scene of terrible violence hatred and
evil around 2:30 yesterday afternoon
police responded to reports of gunfire
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
in parkland Florida a great and safe
community there a shooter was now in
custody opened fire on defense of
students and teachers he murdered 17
people and badly wounded at least 14
others our entire nation with one heavy
heart is praying for the victims and
their families so naturally folks on the
Left immediately suggested that because
Trump said that we're praying for the
victims this means we don't want to do
anything it means that we don't care as
opposed to one President Obama would
speak after shooting when he would
fulminate against Congress and suggest
that we need some sort of vast gun
confiscation or if not a vast gun
confiscation some sort of gun control
that probably would have done little to
stop the shooting so let's let's move
beyond the implication that folks we
disagree with are obviously uncaring
unfeeling crude barbarous people who
don't care when small children and high
schoolers are cut short in the prime of
their lives before they even had a
chance to have
full life by evil sick human beings
let's let's put that aside because if we
can't put aside the implication that
folks we disagree with are evil and
nasty then we can't have a political
discussion if you really think if you're
on the left today and you really think
that folks on the right don't care about
what happened in parkland and that what
you're dealing with is an ultimately
evil group of people who do not care at
all when innocents get shot then maybe
it's time for you to arm up yourself and
go fight those people because only
monsters would not care what happened in
parkland Florida yesterday so what
exactly did happen in parkland for war
heroes a school shooting eyewitness
talking about the harrowing the
harrowing events today around like 2:22
and you would like to push us because we
already had a fire along drilling off so
we weren't sure if this is the real fire
or not and apparently I guess the
shooter pulled the alarm so you could
have kids going on on the hallway to
shoot and I was on the top floor and
then right behind right below me on the
first floor I heard shooting and I saw
two guys running I went to make a right
and I just ran and I had my book bag on
my back just in case I got shot in the
back it would go through my book bags in
my book I ran to where there were
students and teachers on the seal from
there I knew it was real shooting so
three helicopters and everyone was so
the shooter whose name you know I'm I'm
starting to believe I've always been
conflicted about this there are a lot of
folks who say you should not mention the
identity of the shooter you shouldn't
mention the name of the shooter and I'm
starting to believe that's right because
the glorification of these shooters is
obviously driving other people to to
worship them since Columbine a huge
percentage of school shooters have
worshiped at the altar the folks who
were responsible for Columbine the
monster is responsible for Columbine so
I'm to avoid mentioning the name of the
shooter today I'm going to talk about
what we need to know about him and I'm
not gonna mention his name because I
don't think they're giving him
credibility or giving him fame is is a
worthwhile thing because these crimes do
these crimes do tend to create copycats
but here is Matthew Walker Matthew
I was a student at the school and he was
discussing with the media what he saw
and also what he knew about the shooter
honestly all people were saying that it
was gonna be him stuff like that we
actually we do all kids do drugs I like
that saying that here's me the one that
screwed up the school but it turns out
you know everyone predicted it it's it's
that's crazy yeah he was in the third
floor he knows the school layout he
knows where every woman would be at as
of right now he's been in this on fires
oh so he's prepared for this stuff okay
and this shooter they're always always
in this case many many red flags about
this shooter
his Instagram was filled with pictures
of him holding up guns you can see this
picture of his of his Instagram
flaunting his weapons he was a he was on
law enforcement's radar as well
the New York Post has a long a long
story about it the suspected gunman is a
troubled former student obsessed with
firearms whose once identified as a
potential threat to his fellow
classmates according to a report one
teen said I stayed cleared of him most
of the time he's been a troubled kid
he's always had a certain amount of
issues going on
he shot guns because he felt it gave him
I guess an exhilarating feeling he
showed me his guns personally through
his phone
this particular shooter he even joked
about taking out his schoolmates on
several occasions the team says he
played around with the joke multiple
times you know he knows the layout of
the school he can actually go ahead he
can pinpoint where all the students
would be he's been through the drills
multiple time he'd been banned from
carrying a backpack on the campus of
this high school due to his alleged
issues according to the Miami Herald a
math teacher said we were told last year
he wasn't allowed on campus with a
backpack on him it's gym guard a math
teacher who taught this shooter last
year he said there were problems with
him last year threatening students I
guess he was asked to leave campus
according to the teacher
school officials that sends out an email
warning teachers about about the shooter
and the alleged threats that he was
making against other students the
Broward County School Superintendent
said this didn't happen he said we
received no warnings I don't really
believe that apparently the FBI received
warnings as well and I will give you
more details on that in just one second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at keeps so you know if
you are getting into your 30s and you
look at your dad and you say well my dad
is losing all his hair my dad happens to
be a guy who who went we could start to
bald in his late 30s and in his 40s and
so I worry deeply about losing my hair
that is why keeps is such
so keeps is the easiest way to keep your
hair it offers the only two hair loss
products that are clinically proven to
keep the hair you have there only two
that have been approved by the FDA that
actually fight hair loss and keep
provides you with the options of either
one you can sign up in less than five
minutes keeps this entirely online and
it's only 10 to 35 bucks a month so
there's one dollar a day or less on
average which is indeed half of what you
typically pay at the pharmacy for for
some of these drugs so the the products
that are that are used for your for your
head typically cost a lot of money if
you get them through a doctor and you
have to go down to CVS and pick them up
keeps make sure that they are much much
more much much less expensive rather
keep getting start with them is really
easy answer a few questions you snap
some photos and then a licensed doctor
remotely reviews your information and
gives you the right prescription all
without you ever leaving your couch
within two to three days a three-month
supply of your treatment will arrive
perfectly packaged at your door I use
keeps because I want to maintain my hair
and I know lots of other people do as
well stop hair loss today the easy way
with keeps offering customized treatment
plans with only in clinic the only
clinically proven hair loss products for
about a buck a day from the comfort of
your couch to receive your first month
of treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash Ben that's that's ke EPS calm
slash men isn't like keeping your hair
keeps calm slash Ben it's a free month
of treatment at keeps calm slash Ben it
keeps your hair today and make sure that
it's there for tomorrow because once you
start losing it folks it ain't gonna
grow back in all likelihood and that's
why you need these hair loss products
before you actually start experiencing
all of the hair loss go to keeps calm
slash bending at your first three months
of treatment so check that out alright
so more information on this shooter so
according to the Broward County Schools
district superintendent Robert one C he
said potentially there could have been
signs out there but we didn't have any
warning or phone calls or threats that
were made but his classmates the
shooters classmates a he was well known
threat at the school a lot of people
were saying that it was going to be him
right one of the one of the students
said everything he posts is about
weapons it's sick and they are looking
at some of the motives behind all of
this but apparently he was a loner he
was law enforcement says he was a member
of the of J ROTC junior Reserve Officer
Training Corps he was apparently in an
alternative school in an alternate
school and he and people didn't want to
be
near him he was reportedly wearing a gas
mask and carrying smoke grenades during
the alleged massacre it's not clear
where he got the smoke grenades he
apparently used an ar-15 two-to-three
and which is a semi-automatic most
commonly owned semi-automatic rifle in
the United States that was legally
garnered he had it legally apparently he
bought it legally the smoke grenades no
one knows where those came from or
whether he got those legally at all we
also know that the FBI was apparently
warned last September about this guy so
there was a youtube user who used his
real name this guy used his real name
and he wrote in response to a video by a
V logger that he was going to be a co
professional school shooter and that V
logger warned the FBI on Thursday
BuzzFeed reported the FBI been warned
about someone of the same name in late
September 2017
BuzzFeed spoke with the YouTube viewer
Ben tonight 36 you said he noticed an
alarming response to one of his videos
posted and immediately contacted the FBI
agent the bureau's Mississippi field
office got back to him immediately Ben
ID said and conducted an in-person
interview the following day on September
25th according to BuzzFeed they came to
my office the next morning they asked if
I knew anything about the person I
didn't said the v-log or they took a
copy of the screen shot and that was the
last I heard from them so you can
actually see the screenshot in which the
shooter says I'm going to be a
professional school shooter and uses his
actual name and is not an alias it is it
is not a it is not a pseudonym when I
told BuzzFeed that around 4:30 on
Wednesday 30 minutes after they took the
shooter into custody Special Agent Ryan
fer of the Miami FBI field office
contacted him about the shooter he said
quote I think we spoke with you in the
past about a complaint you made about
someone making a comment on your YouTube
channel I just wanted to follow up with
you on that and ask you a question with
something that's come up if you wouldn't
mind giving me a ring so the agents
visit him in person for a second time on
Wednesday they asked me if I knew who he
was I didn't I don't then they left I
guess so it's it's vlog or not was not
to be long or sorry in any case the FBI
refused to acknowledge that they made
this call or that this guy was on their
their list according to former classmate
Joshua Charo 16 he said all you talk
about his guns and knives and hunting I
can't say I was shocked from past
experiences he seemed like the kind of
kid who would do something like this he
used to tell me he would shoot rats with
his BB gun and he wanted this kind of
gun and how he always liked to shoot for
practice apparently he escaped the
school by hiding among the other
students evacuating the area but then
who's arrested in
by neighborhood around 4 p.m. so
obviously shocking stuff so here's the
question now so the question is what do
we do the question is what do we do
there are some stories of heroism that
I'm gonna talk to you about in a few
minutes but what do we do about
situations like this so the Republicans
do what the Republicans typically do
right they say we need to wait to find
out exactly what's happening here so
Marco Rubio says listen and the senator
from Florida it's his home state he said
we don't know how this happened yet in
order for us to fight
what exactly happened we have to know
what exactly happened and how exactly it
happened here is Rubio saying this he
just got shellacked on media over this
oh it's not only because people don't
they don't know how this happened who
this person is what motivated them how
did they get ahold of the weapon that
they use for this attack I think it's
important to know all that before you
jump to conclusions that there's some
law that we could have passed it could
have prevented it and there may be but
shouldn't we at least know the facts and
so I think that you can always have that
debate but if you're gonna have the
debate about this particular incident
you should know the facts of that
incident before you run out and
prescribe some law that you claim could
have prevented it I've seen a lot of
that on television and maybe there is a
law that could have prevented this
instance but we don't know that and
neither do they that's exactly right but
people were saying how dare he say this
how dare he listen glenn kessler fact
check this statement by rubio rubio made
a similar statement last year saying all
the gun laws that have been proposed
wouldn't have stopped a lot of these
school shootings and glenn kessler who
is no right winger over at the
washington post concluded that this was
true because of course it's true right
the fact is that in this particular case
if some of it here's the deal in a
country with 300 million weapons and
there are 300 million guns in the united
states if you are determined to go and
hit a soft target with no security
present you are going to find a way to
do it you are it is not hard to
illegally obtain a gun in the united
states forget about the rules it is not
hard to be legally obtain a gun in the
United States it is not hard to make
illegal modifications to a legally
obtained weapon it is not difficult to
carry out a terror attack and this was
essentially a terror attack there is it
there is no reason that you can't do
that which brings us to question number
two well there are two questions one
what can we do to minimize the chances
that this happens and number two how do
we maximize the chances that the
response time is the shortest so that we
can kill somebody like this before
they're able to do any more damage so
the answer to question number one there
some things that we can probably do and
Jim Garrity over at National Review has
suggested for example that we really
crack down in more harsh fashion on
straw purchase or straw purchasers are
people who buy a gun and then
transferred illegally to somebody so I
buy a gun illegally and then there's
somebody I know who can't get a gun and
so I transfer that gun legally to that
person that makes me a straw buyer
that's illegal in the last 10 years or
something only 44 people have been
prosecuted in serious fashion as straw
purchasers despite the fact that there
are thousands of these people who are
out there right that obviously needs to
stop with that of stop this school
shouldnt know because this guy had no
criminal record there was no record of
him having been institutionalized I
believe for any significant period of
time that would barred him promoting a
weapon and that means that it's very
difficult to see how he wouldn't been
able to get the weapon the only way he
would've been able to be barred from
having the weapon is if the FBI did
their damn job right if the FBI actually
investigated found this guy worn local
law enforcement now apparently this
shooter was also on the radar for local
law enforcement apparently his mom had
called up his mom I think recently
passed away apparently his mom had
called up the police and they'd had like
sit-down sessions with this kid so there
are a lot of red flags
everybody was warning about him and
nobody was able to do anything so maybe
one of the things that we should do as a
preventative measure is make it easier
to involuntarily commit somebody like
this who sounds like he's a sociopath
and maybe we should make it less
difficult for family to say listen we
can't control somebody like this this
person is dangerous right now the law in
most states across the Union across the
United States is that we will only put
you on a 48-hour hold a 48 hour
psychiatric hold if you are a danger to
yourself or others and then if you can
show that you're not a danger to
yourself or others we release you again
well that's probably not enough an
involuntary commitment in the United
States is incredibly difficult very very
tough maybe that needs to change because
how many of these school shooters have
been people who should have been in
psychiatric care it sounds like this guy
was crazy it sounds like the Jared Lee
Loughner in Arizona was crazy it sounds
like they James who else up the the
wasn't I can't remember his name the the
evil guy who shot up a theater in in
Aurora Colorado that guy was crazy
obviously Adam Lanza the the shooter in
Sandy Hook was a crazy person i all of
these people should have been forcibly
incarcerated for psychiatric care they
were not there's something wrong with
that system I mean we have to have heavy
screening we don't want
innocent people being forcibly in the
forcibly institutionalized but we do
want to make sure that if you have a
real mental illness and you're a threat
to others that you're not out on the
streets able to walk into a school and
start shooting it up so that's something
that you get there a couple things you
can do right off the bat to stop this
background checks would that have
stopped this case no because again there
was nothing for them to check he had no
criminal record they did the only way
that you could presumably stop somebody
like him from buying that weapon is to
ban the weapon outright banned the sale
of the weapon outright so that's what
the left is starting proposed now is
let's ban the sale of the weapon
outright that probably would not have
stopped this particular case because
again if you are determined there are
too many guns in the United States to
prevent the illegal sale of some of a
gun to somebody who wants one and unless
you're unwilling to undergo a full-scale
gun confiscation which are talking about
hundreds of millions of weapons across
the United States which would not go
down without significant violence
particularly in gun heavy areas then
you're not talking in the real world
you're just not speaking about things
that are happening in the real world in
Australia the gun violence rate has gone
down at a lower rate than the United
States despite the gun confiscation the
gun confiscation only took one-third of
the guns that was the gun buyback
program in Australia
and see legal for people to own guns
two-thirds of the people who owned them
still own them so the idea people are
just gonna turn over their weapons is
insane it's not going to happen so then
it becomes a question of what can we do
practically and a lot of the measures
that the left talks about wouldn't do
anything practically when they say ban
assault weapons okay so what do you mean
by assault weapon
you mean the grip I mean the way that
the stock attaches and what are you
talking about assault weapon you're
gonna ban all rifles because again
you're gonna need a mass confiscation if
you actually want that to work so this
is where the the rubber hits the road
there are a lot of polls that suggest
that Americans want more gun control
these polls are pretty much meaningless
they're about as meaningless as the
polls that say that Americans want
spending cuts right we want spending
cuts until you tell us what it is that
you want to cut Americans want gun
control until you tell us what it is
that you want to control if you're
telling us that you want background
checks we're pretty much all for that
they exist if you buy from a federally
licensed firearms dealer as happened in
this case
and you fail the background check you
can't buy that gun that exists people
don't like to talk about the gun show
loophole the idea of hand-to-hand
transfers there's not a ton of evidence
that dad is connected to crime
hand-to-hand transfers that I legally
sell my gun to Mathis for example
there's not a lot of evidence that that
is good that that has any impact on
crime
but that's not stopping the left from
making from from making hay while the
Sun shines politically and that's where
I really object is again going back to
the original point people on the left
continue to insist over and over and
over again that if I want to look
specifically at what measures they're
pushing then this means that I'm doing
something wrong instead I should just
give them a blank check because
something terrible and evil just
happened okay in just a second I'm going
to show you the Democratic response to
this and where I think it is morally
deficient but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at movement so
you've heard me talk incessantly about
movement I love my movement watches and
I say watches because I have two of them
my wife has one my mom has one my dad
has one everyone that I know has a
movement watch and the reason for that
is not just because I get them for them
as presents but also because movement
watches are the best movement watches
are terrific they are inexpensive they
are really solid they look fantastic
movement it used to be a bunch of
crowdfunded kids working out of a living
room but in the last year they've also
introduced not only a bunch of new watch
collections from both men and women but
expanded it to sunglasses and
fashion-forward bracelets as well
movement watches are all about looking
good keeping it simple they don't tell
you how many they don't tell you how
many steps you've taken or they blow
your wrists up with text messages
instead they're classic looking watches
clean they look fantastic they look a
lot more expensive than they would in a
department store it's like 400 500
dollar watches at a department store
instead
movement watches are at 95 bucks so
check it out right now you have 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns when you go to MVM t.com slash
shapiro that's MVM t.com slash shapiro
when you use that slash apparel again
yeah 15% off today so that's MVM t calms
slash appear use the slash capiro so
they know that we sent you movement
watches they're fantastic I've endorsed
them over and over for years I will
continue to do so not only because
they're an advertiser but also because
they're just great again I have one that
silver I have one that's black movement
watches are first-rate you won't regret
it
they make a great battle and post if
you're laid up for Valentine's Day and
you blew it with your with your honey
then the movement watch is something
that can help fix that MVM t comm slash
imperial for 15% off okay so the
democrats in the media respond to this
shooting with their usual excitement and
alacrity and they they are not excited
obviously people got trapped but excited
that then now they get to push this
issue into the forefront once again so w
Wasserman Schultz she comes down she
says it's not too soon
talk about this now what the left never
says is what this is I said they'll
never it's never too soon to talk about
gun control okay what do you mean by gun
control and what does that mean what
specific proposal are you putting on the
table and if you don't have one then
what exactly are we talking about here
I hate vague terminology I think that
it's useless in politics and it's
counterproductive in politics and in
fact all it is for the left is a
buzzword when the Democrats controlled
Congress we made 60 votes in the Senate
and a majority in the House and the
presidency they didn't pass one piece of
solid gun control legislation they could
have they didn't then it was unpopular
they knew the American people wouldn't
like it they knew that in many cases it
probably would have been
unconstitutional but here is Debbie
wasserman-schultz again saying it's not
too soon just to talk about gun control
listen I am happy to talk about gun
control but you need to show me what is
the specific piece of legislation we are
discussing what is your specific
proposal then we can talk about it
otherwise you're just saying I don't
like guns is as useless as you saying I
don't like nuclear weapons okay I'm not
a huge fan of nuclear weapons either
they do a lot of damage but we have to
talk in serious policy terms about the
cost and benefits of the United States
having nuclear weapons now the same
thing is true with regard to private
ownership of guns
okay here's w Wasserman Schultz the
doing the routine it's absolutely not
too soon to yet again say that something
has to be done about access to guns in
this country but just as important
something has to be done about making
sure that people who have mental health
challenges get the help that they need
okay so if we all agree with that on the
mental health challenges the people who
have mental health problems ought to get
the help that they need
then we needed strength in the system I
think we all agree on that and there are
ways that we can strengthen the
enforcement of preventing mentally ill
people from getting guns in the state of
California there a couple of years ago
there were 30,000 people in the state of
California who were on the rolls as
people who should not be able to own
guns that we knew own guns and we had a
twenty person team trying to track them
down and take away their guns okay that
ain't gonna cut it
so strong law enforcement would be
useful here and here there should be
some points of agreement will there be
unclear one of the reasons that are may
not be is because when it comes down to
actual boiling down of this stuff to
legislation things become a lot more
complicated so for example there are a
bunch of people online who have now been
claiming that Donald Trump rolled back
an Obama rule on back
ground checks for gun ownership that
they blocked that they they struck down
Obama or a regulation blocking gun sales
to the mentally ill right this is the
line
CNN ran it the hill ran at NPR ran it
right the idea being that Republicans
made it easier for mentally ill people
to get guns that is not what the House
Republicans were doing that is not what
it was Charlie cook writes about this
over at National Review he says this was
yet another sort of episode of the press
is having a breakdown coupled with a
special installment of celebrity suite
falsehoods without knowing it contrary
to the AP suggestion the background
check system remains in place contrary
to the hills implication the rule of
change in question did not repeal the
limitations on the severely mentally ill
none of that happened because most
people read headlines and ignore the
articles underneath both Twitter and
Facebook were full of talk last night
about the perfidy of the house so here
is what exactly happened here okay there
was a rule that Obama era rule was not
that gun buyers must obtain background
checks or the mentally ill are barred
from buying guns and it wasn't an NRA
initiative it was an ACLU initiative
right the NRA and the ACLU both
supported what the house did why because
here's what it was about the rule would
require the Social Security
Administration to forward the names of
all Social Security disability insurance
and Supplemental Security income
recipients who use a representative
payee to help manage their benefits due
to a mental impairment to the National
instant instant criminal background
check system so bureaucrats within one
federal agency would be able to say that
old people who are no longer able to
take care of their finances should have
their guns removed from them and be used
this should be used as a definition of
mental defective there are a bunch of
problems with this so as Charlie says on
separation of power grounds the prospect
of the Social Security Administration
playing judge jury and executioner is
flatly intolerable on due process
grounds there was nothing to recommend
the measure on statutory grounds it
seems clear the SSA was acting all
treviris I mean out of their authority
and it's a political matter the
vacillation of the Obama administration
which insisted simultaneously that
incidents of violence continue to
highlight a crisis in America's mental
health system and that it was not
attempting to imply a connection between
mental illness and a propensity for
violence was downright embarrassing
again the the link also between
financial acumen being able to take care
of your finances and being able to own a
gun that link is really weak I know a
lot of people who are not capable of
handling their finances and most of
those people are
still able to handle a gun it doesn't
matter the left trotted out this
nonsense anyway all day yesterday and
you're still seeing it today Blumenthal
a senator senator Blumenthal from New
Jersey from Connecticut rather Richard
Blumenthal he was doing the same routine
as debbie Wasserman Schultz however and
blaming Congress for not doing enough
even though he can make no specific
proposal that would have stopped what
happened yesterday this one is the 18th
school shooting just this year but also
the day-by-day deaths that are
preventable and we have an obligation to
prevent Congress has been complicit
Congress bears responsibility so when
they say Congress has been complicit
then you hear the MSNBC ghost MSNBC host
Koch mmm-hmm yes yes it just shows you
how stupid this whole conversation is
explain how they've been complicit
explain the law that they should have
passed that they didn't pass explain
what they did wrong don't you say
Congress has been complicit on a broad
level and that something bad happens
Congress isn't God okay there are
certain things that should have been
done here it sounds like the FBI blew it
and our great house hello to FBI but the
idea that the Congress is responsible
for this without mentioning what
proposal Congress voted down is beyond
incipit also the left keeps implying for
example there a bunch of pieces of
misinformation going around today
another piece of misinformation going
around the NRA is paying off politicians
to be pro-gun that is not the case okay
there was a rumor going around on the
left
it's a Stephanie ruhle I believe on
MSNBC really suggesting that it's just
just terrible that there was one senator
who received three million dollars over
the last ten years from the NRA okay
that Senator spent thirty million
dollars on his last senatorial race
alone if you think that he moved from
anti-gun to pro-gun because the NRA paid
him off you're an idiot
another piece of bad information that
you're seeing parented by the media
there's a group called every town every
town is a gun control group and every
town said that there were 18 school
shootings in the month of January now
you may be wondering why didn't I hear
about those school shootings every
single day the answer is because there
were not 18 school shootings in the
month of January they're more like three
okay even one is terrible but there were
no mass school shootings and the and the
ones that exist are bad enough without
you having to blow it up to 18 and we
can go through them by ABC News said
there were 18 school shootings in the
first 45 days of 2018 according to every
town then New York Daily News said the
same thing but that's not
true ok twice so they counted these
these as gun incidents on campus why
someone shot themselves on a school
grounds one incident on January 3rd
featured a man shooting himself in a
former schools parking lot On January
10th the teen killed himself in an
Arizona elementary school bathroom hey
that is not a school shooting that is a
school suicide hey four times a bullet
was fired through a school or dorms
window a gunshot on January 4th was
fired at a high school in Seattle from
an office window no one was hurt On
January 10th the shot was fired
shattering a California University
classroom window no injuries reported
the same day in Texas a bullet was
accidentally fired through a classroom
the wall at the Greyson College Criminal
Justice Center no one injured On January
15th a bullet traveled through a
residential halls dorm room but no
injuries reported when January 25th a
Mobile Alabama high school student fired
a gun on campus no injuries On January
26 kotzwara shots were fired from a car
in a parking lot no injuries on February
5th a third grader pulled the trigger on
a cop's gun no one was injured On
February 8th the shot was fired inside
metropolitan high school no one was
injured
ok there have only been a few cases in
which someone was injured
other than the shooter January 22nd in
Texas a teenage girl was wounded by
shots from a semi-automatic handgun at
the same day a 14 year old boy was
injured in a shooting in in Gentilly
Louisiana February first five children
were injured in an accidental shooting
so that's not even a purposeful shooting
it's accidental and finally on February
5th a teenager was shot and injured
outside of high school there are only
three deadly shootings apparently in the
last 45 days so that is still awful
every one of these is awful every one of
these is tragic and terrible and and an
active evil that does not mean that 18
happened so I think that it's just
important to get the statistic correct
like this is that you wonder why them
people don't trust the media it's cuz
the media don't bother to do any of this
they just give you the bottom line 18
school shootings and then the minute you
dig into it you realize there are not 18
school shootings there were three right
a football player was shot and killed in
winston-salem North Carolina in Benton
Kentucky two people were killed another
15 shot at Marshall County High School
January 31st there was a fight that
broke out in a Pennsylvania high school
and a 32 year old man was shot and later
died so that is not the same as what the
media have been telling you but the
media's malfeasance here has been really
quite awful and we're gonna talk about
the media malfeasance here in just a
second but first you're gonna have to go
over to Daily wire and subscribe for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire that means that you got
the rest of my show live get the rest of
mandrill clayvin still alive you get the
red you get the rest of the terrible
Michael Noel's show live as well I
wouldn't be doing the mail
tomorrow so if you want your questions
answered in the mailbag then today is
they need to sign up so that you can
answer you can ask your questions by
submitting or you can ask them live and
we will read them aloud and answer it
make your life better you get all of
that plus be fabled leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr it is fantastic
it holds beverages better than any other
vessel on planet earth you will love it
so check it out with your annual
subscription ninety-nine dollars a year
which is a lot cheaper than $9.99 a
month it is in fact twenty dollars
cheaper look at that amazing math okay
so check that up if you wanna listen
later for free iTunes SoundCloud YouTube
subscribe to us at YouTube please leave
us a review on iTunes or Apple podcasts
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so as I say the media response to the
shooting has been filled with with lies
and untruths and half-truths and what it
really is about is folks in the media
demonstrating how much they care this
has become the game and it's a it's not
a game in the sense that none of this is
really a game but this has become what
the media do what the media do in the
aftermath of a shooting is they
demonstrate how deeply they care all the
late night hosts go out there and talk
about gun control even though a simple a
simple note of sympathy would suffice
they decide that they become experts on
gun control members of the media go out
there and talk about how how much they
care because in American society for
some odd reason we have decided that we
can judge whether you are making a
quality proposal by the level of how
much you care
this is stupid politics the level of how
much you care has nothing to do with the
decency strength or truth of a proposal
that you are making but nonetheless
these emotional pleas continue from the
media there's a commentator named
Cavanaugh on NBC saying that the
argument against gun control is
legitimately over there is no more
argument Dunst gun control because of
the shooting the argument that gun
safety laws don't work has it I mean
it's it's jumped shark week it's gone
look at these mass killings that
argument is gone we need to have
reasonable laws not take away anybody's
rights everybody's got to work together
are we making the Second Amendment a
suicide pact for all of us our children
the mall the school the college this is
crazy
and we can do better okay that is ATF
special agent Jim Cavanaugh a law
enforcement analyst solid
law-enforcement analysis they're
reasonable gun laws that don't violate
anyone's rights why that's how it's just
magical now what the hell are you
talking about I can really make a
proposal put it on the table let's
discuss it but don't give me the
reasonable gun laws and then don't
actually propose a gun law right you
can't do that that's not fair it's not
right and it's not true it's just
foolishness and more than more than
anything else it's designed to put
people who are in favor of gun rights on
the defensive oh well you're
unreasonable see if you if you disagree
with Gemma Kavanaugh that there is a
case against gun control then that means
that you're unreasonable it means that
you don't care it means that you're a
bad person this is what I said to Piers
Morgan years ago after the Sandy Hook
shooting did he stand on the graves of
the kids Sandy Hook and Ramon
political agenda unfortunately members
of the media still play this game if you
cannot assume good intentions on the
part of your political opponent you're
never gonna be able to make a deal
you're certainly not gonna be able to
come to any sort of conclusion it wasn't
just Cavanaugh Don Lemon on CNN made an
emotional plea for gun control after the
school shooting so just forget politics
here this is about lives the lives of
all Americans we need to keep guns out
of the hands of dangerous people
everyone agrees with that people who
oppose gun control will say today is not
the day to talk about it and you know
what they are absolutely right because
the day to talk about it was weeks
months years or decades ago and yes of
course we also need to make mental
health a priority in this country but
guess what we can do both we can do both
of those things at the same time if we
don't we have no one to blame but
ourselves
this is America people don't forget that
ok yeah I got this is America I mean I
like Don but but I mean come on come on
yes this is America guess what's in our
Constitution a Second Amendment that's
part of America and this idea that we're
we're all sitting around wailing and
gnashing our teeth over over stuff that
over meaningless slogans and then the
stuff should've been done years ago
make your case make your proposal I
don't understand you have a secret
proposal is it like Trump's is it like
Trump's foreign policy on Isis that he
wasn't gonna reveal during the campaign
or dick Nixon's proposal on how to end
the Vietnam War in five minutes like
what's your proposal we've been around
I'm waiting put it on the table let's
talk about it but we're not getting any
of that instead we get the we cannot
accept this right America is better than
this whenever people say things like
America is better than this it's so
irritating because this is the
suggestion is if I disagree with your
general proposition on policy and that
means I don't think America is better
than this I think America is worse than
this I think people deserve to be shot
he wasn't even the worst person on CNN
last night that was Philip Mudd Philip
Mudd is the national security analyst
counterterrorism analyst over at CNN he
teared up and then he started talking
about we cannot accept this I have ten
nieces and nephews we're talking about
bump stocks we're talking about
legislation a child of God is dead
cannot we acknowledge in this country
that we can we cannot accept this I
can't deal with absurd
we can't do it your ups okay do you
think we all don't feel like that you
think we all don't feel like that we
cannot accept this is such an obnoxious
statement of course we can't accept this
who are you implying can't accept this
are you implying that a bunch of us who
own guns accept this
we're the ones who want to stand out
there and shoot this bastard before he
enters the school are you suggesting
that those of us who think the best
solution is would be armed security are
accepting this on the contrary okay I
went to a Jewish day school here in Los
Angeles for high school it's a high
school called you should be University
of Los Angeles or your ship of love Los
Angeles it changes name a couple of
times it's right next to the Simon
Wiesenthal Center every month probably
once a month we had to evacuate the
school because of a bomb threat because
it's a Jewish school and that means
they're an C's Matic bomb and threats on
a pretty regular basis while I was there
there was a guy named Buford furo okay
Buford furrow was a was a tin actual
white supremacist terrorist
I graduated from eula in 2000 he in 1999
shot up a Jewish Community Center in the
West Valley here in Los Angeles and
before he did that he drove past our
high school he drove to the high school
he stopped at the Simon Wiesenthal
Center he thought about going in and he
saw security guards he wrongly assumed
they were armed they were not armed but
he wrongly assumed that they were armed
security guards and he thought to
himself okay I can either walk in here
and get my ass shot or I can go to a
place where there will be no security
like the JCC and then I can shoot up as
many people as I want he ended up
killing several people and it is and the
the point of the story is that security
at schools matters for the left which
which is constantly suggested the
government stimulus who behead by
creation of government jobs how about
this how about the government local
government state government how about
they pay for security at their schools
how about we make sure that there are
armed guards several armed guards on
every school campus it's not too much to
ask we have armed security guards at
malls for goodness sake why shouldn't we
have them at schools we have a bunch of
sitting ducks students the most valuable
commodity are our society has kids and
they're utterly unprotected and you
stick a gun-free sticker up there and
you think that's gonna somehow dissuade
people from walking on campus with a gun
I don't understand why this is even
mildly unreasonable why how is it
unreasonable to suggest that maybe we
ought to have armed people who are
qualified with the gun standing there to
make sure that other
people can't walk into school this guy
walked in there with a full-on rifle he
wasn't concealing it he was banned from
campus and when people say well you
can't do identity checks at the door in
school why the hell not
why can't you identity checks in school
we had one in my high school this idea
that oh you're militarizing the school
you know what the security at my
daughter's pretty school is really good
militarizing schools you know what
militarize is a school somebody walking
in with a gun and murdering students
that militarized the school you know it
doesn't militarized a school having a
security guard everybody knows their
name and their friends with who knows
how to use a gun and it's capable of
doing that in case a bad person walks on
campus with a gun this notion that
you're going to protect students by
doing none of that that they're fragile
psyches let me let me tell you something
what's more fragile than a student's
psyche their body and this idea that
students are so fragile psychically that
if they see a man with a gun in a
uniform maybe see cops on campus or if
they see a security guard on campus with
a gun not a security monitor with a
stupid radio an actual gun if they see
that person this is going to disturb
them it's going to make them unable to
function in a normal society what kind
of stupid crap is this what absolute
utter nonsense you don't know what's a
middle school there are there are
security guards with guns in Israel
every school has a security guard with a
gun or multiple are the kids from Israel
somehow really screwed up because they
saw a gun only people who are idiots
think that the mere sight of a gun
traumatized a child so much that they'll
never recover
you know what traumatize a child being
shot you know traumatize a child seeing
their classmates shot you know
traumatized a child hiding in a closet
texting their parents that there might
be about to die because there was no one
on campus with a gun to stop a bad man
who walks onto campus with a gun so
listen I'm happy so what can gun control
proposals if they are actually specific
so we can determine what is true and
what is not what I am not willing to do
is entertain the idea that if you just
say gun control I'm supposed to bow to
whatever you fill in that blank check
with and meanwhile I'm supposed to
pretend that it's not idiocy not to have
armed security guards on campus just
stupidity now that's how there's
something else interesting that was
tweeted out yesterday Michael Ian Black
was a comedian he tweeted something out
about how there is something deeper than
the gun problem happening in the United
States I think he's half right and half
wrong here's what he tweeted quote
deeper even than the gun
as this boys are broken until we fix men
we need to fix the gun problem the last
50 years redefined womanhood women were
taught they can be anything no
commensurate movement for men who are
still generally locked into the same
rigid outdated model of masculinity and
it's killing us if you want to hurt a
man the first thing you do is attack his
masculinity men don't have the language
to understand masculinity is anything
other than some version of a caveman
because no language exists the language
of masculinity is hopelessly entwined
with sexuality and the language of
sexuality is hopelessly entwined with
power agency and self-worth so men and
boys before that don't have language
from modes of expression that don't
readily conform to traditional standards
to step outside those norms is to take a
risk most of us are afraid to take as a
result a lot of guys spend their lives
terrified
we're terrified as being viewed as
something other than men we know
ourselves to be men but we don't know
how to be our whole selves a lot of us
me included either shutoff or experience
deep shame or rage or all three again
men are terrified even talking about
this topic invites ridicule because it's
so scary for most men and women men are
adrift and nobody is talking about it
and nobody's doing anything about it and
it's killing us I think that he has a
point that boys are broken I think
that's true but his suggestion than what
is happening here is basically that men
have been told that they ought to act
like men that this is corrupted manhood
is nonsense if there was a collapse in
manhood over the last 50 years you have
to ask what changed what changed in the
model of manhood was the definition of
manhood manhood used to be about being a
protector I don't have to read you the
sheepdog speech here from American
sniper but that's what being a man was
about that being a man what I will say
the main message the main message in if
you haven't seen American sniper very
famous speech by one of the characters
the main message is that men can either
be wolves or sheep or sheep dogs and
he'll be victimizers or they can be the
victimized or they can be the sheepdogs
who ensure that the wolves are kept at
bay the job of men was to protect
innocence that was the number one job of
men not job number two not job number
ten getting laid was not high on the
list playing video games was not high in
the list protecting women and children
was number one on the West it's why
wasn't I tannic went down the ideal was
women and children first that was a good
thing a men are supposed to protect that
is a man's job and and and I'm not
talking about shortcomings in some of
the men at the school because that was
not happening okay there were real men
at this school the real one was a
football coach who was murdered
yesterday coach Aaron Feist was
initially said to be dead then he was
thought to be alive he passed away this
morning apparently he jumped in front of
the bullets in order to stop students
from being shot it's it's really really
sad he worked as a security guard at the
school for at least eight years and
apparently he was when when the shooting
broke out he jumped in front of the
students and was murdered hey there are
men who are willing to be protectors but
the question is not about those men the
question is about people who become
shooters boys particularly are either
they either create or they destroy this
is true Furman time their children
they're either building blocks or
they're knocking the blocks down this is
what boys do that means the boys have to
be trained from a very young age to
build and not to destroy they've been
they have to be told not only not to
destroy but that is their job to build
and the way that you build society the
way you build a community the way that
you build a safe world is with men who
protect human beings from other bad
human beings make men into heroes don't
make them into into feminized versions
of what you wish men were okay
effeminate you can't get rid of manhood
you can't get rid of masculine and nor
would you want to a society without
masculinity is a society that's balanced
to the to the eventual degradation of
civilization what you actually want here
is a manhood a proud manhood that stands
up for women and children that turns men
as heroes that makes men aspire to be
heroes
it doesn't abandon boys and tell them
they're wrong for feeling that
aggressive impulse men are aggressive
it's what they do
channel that aggression toward something
good and you get great civilizations
evil you get evil civilizations but it
must be channeled it's something we
ought to keep in mind as we move forward
in these discussions that something is
happening on a societal level that is
really negative and really nasty and it
goes deeper than the kind of weapons
that are available on the market okay so
there's a lot going on on immigration
but we're gonna save that for tomorrow
because there have been a couple of
immigration plans proposed the white
house is in favor of one not in favor of
the other the one that seems to moving
fastest through the Senate to make a
long story short is a proposal that
essentially allows the illegal
immigrants up till now to be sustained
in the country illegally and to bring in
some family members and even allows a
four month grace period for people who
are entering the country now illegally
to get in and never be deported the
White House has already said they won't
sign that bill
that seems to be the one that's moving
through the Senate will have some more
updates on it tomorrow okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like so
Steven Pinker has a brand new book
called enlightenment now so I haven't
actually read the book yet I'm looking
forward to reading it I ordered it
yesterday he is a psychologist who's
come under heavy scrutiny from the left
not because he's a right-winger Steven
Pinker is not a right wing there like
Sam Harris he's on the political left
but Steven Pinker is willing to discuss
the reality that there is such a thing
as objective truth that some cultures
are better than other cultures that
reason makes a difference and that the
Enlightenment was something that was
good now where I think that I'll read
the book and then I'll give a fuller
critique of it but my initial response
and my initial prediction about the book
is that Pinker in taking a somewhat anti
religious view because Pinker is an
atheist from what I understand that in
taking of someone anti religious view
he's ignoring the root fundamentals of
the Enlightenment that I'm a pro
enlightenment guy too but I also
acknowledge where the enlightenment came
from it didn't just spring out of the
minds of man unprompted that there were
there was a whole set of developments
that occurred before that and that we've
ripped away a lot of the developments
undergirding the Enlightenment then we
want to keep the the actual cherry on
top well you can't get rid of the sundae
and keep the cherry on top that's not
how this works
you can't keep the roof of the building
by destroying its foundations but I'll
have to read the book to see if that's
what Pinker actually does it but this
book is doing really well I'm really
glad to see it his book PEEP anchors
book Jordan Peterson's book there are a
lot of people who are in the sciences
people who are now rising up to defend
civilization against the postmodernist
cult that has torn down science torn
down reason torn down humanism not just
secular humanism but religious humanism
and I think that it's important to fight
back against that you know I provide
very often on this show a vision of a
humanity that is in some ways degraded
in some ways degrading but the meaning
that it is degrading over time but the
reality is that as I've said before this
is the best time in human history to
live now the question is what can we
make ourselves to make ourselves the
best selves to take advantage of that
and continue that progress forward
rather than moving backward okay time
for a couple of quick things that I hate
thing that I hate number one so one of
the things that is super irritating
whenever we get into a gun discussion is
how little people on the Left know about
guns while they're talking about them so
we heard the usual shtick about how this
weapon if you held down the trigger that
it was gonna fire a continuous stream of
bullets that's not true it's a
semi-automatic that means every time you
pull the trigger there's one shot that
is fired Stephen King made an ass of
himself on Twitter
here he is tweeting out against Rick
Wilson so Rick Wilson says here a hell
of a lot more likely to be killed in
Florida by an opioid overdose than ms-13
but my base so that was Rick Wilson
ripping on president Trump actually
because that's what Rick Wilson does a
lot she's ripping on Trump for talking
about ms-13 and dangers of the illegal
immigration Stephen King however is an
ignorant so Stephen King tweets
out he's he's a good writer I mean I
like some of his books at least until
the end every one of his books starts
with an interesting premise and finishes
with the entire world burning down so
you can basically skip the first 700
pages of his novels figured there's some
creepy stuff and then just watch
whatever contains small world he's built
burned to the ground well a couple of
children walk away that's always the
ending of every single one of his books
in any case Stephen King tweeted out
don't tell that to the parents of the
kids who got shot in Broward County
today sport so Rick Wilson tweeted out
it'll have a lot more likely to be
killed by an opioid overdose than ms-13
and Stephen King said tell that don't
tell that to the parents the kids who
got shot in Broward County so apparently
he thinks ms-13 is a gun okay and that's
13 is a gang it is not a gun you have to
be an idiot to think this didn't stop
Stephen King though so Stephen King
tweeting out obviously that you're gonna
be kid that somebody's gonna walk into
your school with an ms-13 or something
when well done the Stephen King just
don't tuck honestly don't talk about
things you don't know anything about
Elizabeth Warren also yesterday she made
a fool of herself she spoke to this
Native American group we discussed it at
length yesterday here's what it sounded
like when this very very Native American
woman who is whiter than I am by a score
by a huge margin here wearing her her
traditional Native American garb here is
what she said about her Native American
background it has been an honor to work
with to learn from and represent the
tribes of my home state of Massachusetts
the aquinnah and the Mashpee Wampanoag
so it's a
delight to be here thank you president
Trump likes to talk about Pocahontas yep
so I figured let's talk about Pocahontas
our country's disrespective native
people didn't start with President Trump
it started long before President
Washington took okay okay stop this stop
this nonsense he owns how about
disrespect to Native American people
have a pretending to be one how about
spending your career pretending that you
have Native American ancestry she can
get a job at Harvard as he was a lot
more disrespectful to Native American
Harwich than somebody mocking you for
doing that I will continue to call
Elizabeth Warren folk ohonta sits not
Pocahontas President trumpets Pocahontas
I'll continue to call it focus because
she's not Native American and hijacking
somebody else's culture for specific use
in an affirmative action program seems
pretty wild to me and yet there she was
talking about how she's gonna stand up
in an affinity of American people just
ridiculous the fact that the left goes
along with this demonstrates that even
identity politics has to take a backseat
to leftism when the rubber meets the
road okay we back here tomorrow we'll
talk about the the immigration planets
moving forward and all of the fallout
from yesterday's horrific heartbreaking
shootings obviously not only do our
thoughts and prayers go out to the
people who were affected by the shooting
but I would love to see some of the
proposals that I made on the program
today yes with regard to straw
purchasers yes with regard to mental
health checks I would like to see some
of those proposals advanced so lest
anyone say that we're not about moving
forward politically we should be moving
forward politically but on a basis of
specific proposals not on the basis of
gun control and therefore you don't care
about what happened everyone cares about
what happened we all stand together on
this and if you don't believe that then
I think that you're doing something
that's that's relatively on american i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing